[Música]
meu nome é ana paula shamrani jogando eu
costumo dizer que o meu nome político é
o nome que eu escolhi porque eu queria
que quando alguém falasse italiana para
chang você imagina se uma pessoa como eu
uma mulher preta escura de dreads de
cabelo natural e ativista shougang
também lado da minha marca que eu creio
que a minha sócia a minha mãe e lá
jogando a gente descobriu que a moda
pode ser uma plataforma de transformação
social pode ser um lugar uma janela para
a gente discutir o mundo pra gente
discute sociedade
é por isso que eu me orgulho muito de si
ateliê desse trabalho que é feito por
mulheres negras na periferia de são
paulo ea gente escolhe está na periferia
principalmente valorizar o nosso
território
ela que eu nasci e é pra lá que eu quero
levar as pessoas para conhecer e para
ampliar a minha arte
além disso eu sou ativista 31 anos
sim a ativista desde quando nasci porque
eu sou filha de pais ativistas
então eu cresci no movimento social na
pastoral de saúde fazendo uma
fiscalização afro fazendo coral negro
teatro negro enfim
cresci no ambiente do ativismo e isso
foi fundamental foi super importante pra
mim e sem dúvida foi o que me formou que
me trouxe até aqui
esse ano a estréia como apresentadora do
gnt no programa de moda num programa de
moda e eu consegui exercitar comunicação
que enfim fui desenvolvendo e aprendendo
e sigo aprendendo a todo tempo mas
provavelmente que me trouxe até aqui é
porque eu tenho um canal e eu faço
conteúdo para a internet a partir de
vídeos textos e reflexões debates
diálogos
eu quero principalmente registrar minha
existência
eu não disse resistência eu disse
existência é isso que eu faço na
internet
faltou dizer que eu sou mãe eu tenho uma
filha linda chama eo luar que eu gosto
de chamar ela de minha pequena potência
coisa de mãe né
bom se ativista é como eu disse para
vocês foi muito importante na minha
traseira
e aí eu percebi que me conectei muito
cedo com racismo infelizmente apesar do
racismo nem sempre têm me atingido
sempre me atacou porque nem sempre
atinge porque como eu disse eu sou filha
de pais muito conscientes de que sempre
me protegeu em algum momento da minha
história eu fui pro mundo e aí sim eu
comecei a minha luta combate ao racismo
foi nesse momento que eu falei ok mãe
obrigada pai eu vou seguir em frente
daqui pra frente
e é isso o racismo sempre foi a minha
principal luta
a principal coisa que eu sempre quis
mudança que o que sempre quis um mundo
melhor ea minha luta o tempo todo em
todos os lugares para onde eu vou
e eu sempre entendi enquanto
continuidade porque eu sou filha de uma
mãe muito forte que agora é sexo
agenário área e é com y porque ela gosta
de ser sexy mesmo
mesmo vencendo ana de um pai muito
presente e de repente eu tenho uma filha
que como eu disse a minha pequena
potência eu me entendo quanto elo entre
essas duas forças
meus pais e minha filha e é claro como
toda mãe
a gente quer fazer o melhor
principalmente quando a gente tem um bom
exemplo de paz em casa
em algum momento da minha história foi
impactada pelo topo da montanha que é
uma peça do lázaro ramos e taís araújo
que com o último dia de martin luther
king quando fui nessa peça principal
mensagem que ficou em mim foi que a
gente precisava passar o bastão passar o
bastão para frente e eu fico me
perguntando que bastam é esse é o bastão
do ativismo da militância da luta contra
o racismo
eu fui pra essa peça grávida e aí quando
eu saí de lá falei ok
em algum momento eu preciso passar o
bastão para minha filha esse bastão que
eu conheço bem porque em algum momento
meus pais também me passaram
eu preciso passar o bastão para minha
filha mas qual será o momento
foi nesse momento que quando chegou a
hora que eu achei que era certo de
passar o bastão para ela não tive
coragem eu não tive coragem de passar o
bastão para a minha filha eu olhava pra
ele falava
acho que ela não merece esse bastão ele
é pesado
cansa desgasta nos destrói
emocionalmente fisicamente eu não quero
passar o bastão da minha filha mas
alguma coisa tinha que fazer com aquele
bastão não podia ficar pra mim porque
minha mãe já tinha me passado eu podia
devolver pra eles e para os meus pais
não podia já fizeram a parte deles a não
mudar então por uma amiga não nas
famílias cada uma tem um bom resolver
nobel maior que o meu não tá bom então
vou passar para uma outra criança mas
será que é justo passar o batom bastam
para outra criança que não vou poder
acompanhar e ajudar a contribuir
só que esse bastão é tipo bastão das
olimpíadas e precisa passar pra frente
pra tocha não parar de queimar
você precisa passar pra frente pra
corrida contra o racismo continuar mas
para minha filha não queria passar até
que eu tive uma brilhante ideia eu falei
eu vou passar isso basta uma pessoa
branca pronto vou passar esse bastão
para uma pessoa branca foi nesse momento
que entende o conceito de branquitude
vocês sabem que existem branquitude no
brasil né
sim existe branquitude no brasil é
engraçado que de negritude todo mundo
sabe falar um pouco todo mundo vai falar
de um samba que adorou de um lugar que
foi de um bloco todo mundo vai cantar
melhor música
todo mundo vai falar sobre a capoeira
sobre o chefe sexta feira
todo mundo vai falar da feijoada todo
mundo é falar de forma superficial ou
profunda sobre a negritude negritude
todo mundo sabe falar e branquitude
quantas vezes vocês discutiram
branquitude foi nesse momento que eu
entendi que branquitude é uma relação de
interdependência só existe negritude
porque existe branquitude se fôssemos
todos os negros não teria a
classificação logo as pessoas precisam
começar a se entender enquanto brancas e
eu confesso que eu comecei a achar
engraçado perguntar para as pessoas me
diz como quando você se descobriu branca
cabelo liso me conta que não sei como é
que eu nunca levei o meu cabelo
mas essas brincadeiras eram provocações
para as pessoas entenderem quanto branca
porque a gente entendeu que ser branco é
normal e que ser negro é o outro mas pra
mim um outro é ser branco chegou um
momento da nossa sociedade que a gente
começar a discutir branquitude e
discutir branquitude para além de
reconhecer os privilégios pensar em
ações anti racistas discutir branquitude
s pensar enquanto ser que se diz
universal discutir branquitude é para
pensar como que é uma entrevista de
emprego está à frente de 54% da
população brasileira
só por ser branco como que é praticar
apropriação cultural porque eu não sei
eu não posso ajudar a ampliação natural
não pratico quando se trata de tranças
dread na sua mulher preta como é ser
branco como é ser branco não ser
preterida nos relacionamentos como o
kers e branca ea e o feminicídio diminui
enquanto para as mulheres negras
aumentou em 54 por cento como kers e
branco como é ser branco e ninguém tocar
no seu cabelo perguntar se você lava ou
não o seu cabelo quando o que a gente
vai discutir branquitude como que essa
maioria nos espaços de poder como que
essa maioria aqui hoje e agora como que
é almoçar no museu e a maioria das
pessoas que serviam eram negras ea
maioria das pessoas estavam comendo eram
brancas e quando perguntei pelo garçom
qual o prato você mais gosta ele falou
nunca come aqui como é ser branco quando
que as pessoas vão realmente se
perguntar qual é a real história da
branquitude o que seus ancestrais
fizeram como eles enriqueceram como que
a casa de dom pedro que no museu foi
construída quem construiu esses tijolos
para dom pedro morar qual é a real
história das botas ancestralidades como
é ser branco
quando eu me fiz essa pergunta e comecei
a repassar essa pergunta que muita gente
não sabe responder
eu falei bingo tô certa eu vou passar o
bastão para uma pessoa branca
por que o racismo não é uma questão dos
negros
a cisão a questão da nossa sociedade e
mais o racismo foi construída construído
estrategicamente historicamente por
pessoas brancas nada mais justo que
essas pessoas começam comecem a assumir
a seleção as suas responsabilidades
históricas e ancestrais e se pergunte o
que vamos fazer enquanto branco para
solucionar o racismo historicamente
criado pela nossos ancestrais
foi nesse momento que eu tive certeza da
minha escolha e pra minha filha e pra
minha filha que essa menina linda eu
mudei de estratégia
eu decidi em vez de passar o bastão
criar uma caixa com as cores do
unicórnio que é o que ela gosta e nessa
caixa eu quero principalmente colocar a
possibilidade dela existir poder ser ser
o que ela quiser
principalmente ser livre mas para que
isso dê certo
eu preciso que outras mãos peguem esse
bastão e hoje eu vim aqui pra passar
esse bastão pra vocês principalmente pra
vocês pessoas brancas porque eu estou
ocupada criando a caixa de sonhos da
minha filha
obrigado
[Aplausos]
num filme
ó
[Aplausos]